it will take
years even
decades to develop the innovations we'll
need to reach net zero emissions by
2050.
in the meantime
we'll have to find ways to adapt to the
effects of climate change that are
already happening of course depending on
your circumstances what will be required
to adapt may be quite different some
will need to find ways to withstand
severe storms and flooding
while others will need to endure
droughts water shortages or wildfires
whatever weather related events each of
us confront having to adapt to climate
change is something we all will share
in this lesson you'll discover how
scientists are developing new crops to
meet changing conditions
what rising sea levels may mean for
hundreds of millions of people around
the globe
and an ingenious way that we might be
able to remove carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere
by relying on the world's beaches
most of us have probably experienced
some consequence of climate change
already unfortunately the frequency and
severity of these events
will get worse
when erratic weather strikes or when
extreme temperatures occur it can be
devastating
when you're a farmer however
you are particularly dependent on the
weather
warmer air temperatures cause the soil
to lose moisture
making it harder to grow crops
plant-eating insects will migrate to new
areas that never had to contend with
them before
cows and sheep will eat less and produce
less milk
worldwide about two-thirds of people in
poverty
work in agriculture many on farms that
are less than four acres of land
these smallholder farms
are
valuable sources of food for both
families and communities
there are over 500 million of them
around the globe
largely in developing countries and
climate change will have a
disproportional impact on them
if these farms
are to continue to be productive and
thrive then farmers are going to have to
find ways to adapt to more volatile
conditions
the ability to grow food as weather
conditions change is something we all
depend on
but for small holder farms the stakes
are especially high
if a crop fails the result can be much
more than just losing food and income it
could mean losing a way of life
an organization whose mission is to help
ensure that farmers can better adapt to
the effects of climate change as a
consultative group for international
agriculture research or one cjirr as
it's now known
founded in 1971 to bring together
various international research centers
one cjiar's primary focus is addressing
food security issues
anna maria lobo guerrero is head of
global policy research for one cjiar
some of the main
challenges that smallholders have right
now it's really being able
to make
small decisions
such as
when to plant
when to apply the water
when to apply the fertilizers
but what has been happening in the past
decades is that it is really hard to
know when you will have this climate
variability in terms of for instance not
having rainfall or having too much
or high temperatures
so these extremes are the ones that have
been changing a lot
and therefore for farmers it's really
hard to understand and to know
what's the best decision in terms of how
to manage their crops basically what we
do is to work together with a variety of
stakeholders
to really being able to transform food
land and water systems
under a climate crisis
so what we do it's research but not only
research
we make sure that our research
is benefiting
millions of stakeholders in food systems
around the world
of all the projects won cjiar has
initiated for adapting to climate change
their work on developing
drought-tolerant and stress-tolerant
maize or corn are among the most
significant
mace is one of the most
important cereals
around the world just to give you an
idea of the magnitude of this
1.2 billion people
in sub-saharan africa and latin america
consume maize and it's one of the most
important sources of food in their
plates also it provides
30 percent of the calorie uptake of
these households it's also used
to feeding animals
drought was one of the most important
things that was decreasing the
productivity of
of mace in many countries so this was a
long-term project in terms of funding in
terms of capacity building which is very
important
and in terms of providing the right
incentives so that the farmers would
use this the varieties that were
developed
by the cgr at the end of the day we
ended up with more than 200 new maze
varieties
that were resilient to drought and that
benefited
around 48 million african people
[Music]
through the techniques that we are using
to develop these varieties we are
considering in our research
issues
such as for instance local cooking
characteristics
because you can have the best variety
that responds really well to droughts
but then if it doesn't taste the way
that farmers are used to
farmers are not going to use it
so it's not convincing them to use them
it's very much
doing the research
and coming up with these varieties
in a way that we are considering those
social factors
into our research and therefore
into the product that we are delivering
so it is not anymore the scientist by
himself by herself
working in the laboratory
coming up with these brilliant ideas
that has not worked
we really need to understand how
these ideas are tailored to
specificities on the ground
how do
they relate with social
variables and with the social dimension
in general
breeding new varieties of
drought-tolerant and stress-tolerant
maize can take years
so farmers don't immediately benefit
from one cjiar's research for some time
it's also very expensive but their
scientists see results
another case in point is a type of rice
that can withstand long-term flooding
cleverly nicknamed scuba rice
this cuba rice is a really interesting
case
uh it was developed but by one of the
one cgr centers
the international rice research
institute also in collaboration with the
university of california
and the idea is that
by using biotechnology techniques and
tools
we were able to produce a new variety of
rice
that could survive
two weeks after after they were
underwater because of flooding
so as you know in asia there are lots of
problems in relation to flooding so we
were able to
deliver this new rice variety
that responded better to these floods
and this has been benefiting more than
eight million farmers that are already
using this new variety and of course
that they are increasing their incomes
but also increasing their food security
because they are not losing their crops
when these floods come
advances like these don't just help
farmers in the face of climate change
however
they are part of the of the group that
are going to be affected in terms of
their livelihoods in terms of their
incomes but it's going to affect
everybody because remember that farmers
are the ones that are responsible for
providing food for the whole population
in the world
so people would be affected in terms of
prices for example uh because of their
reduction of yields because of changes
in climate but that's one side of the
coin but then you need to consider the
other side of the coin which is the one
related to
greenhouse gas emissions and mitigation
so
even though the agricultural sector it's
very much affected by climate change
it's also one of the most important
contributors to climate change
and and this is because there's some
greenhouse gases that have a huge
potential
to warm the environment
one of those gases is methane
and methane is part of what livestock do
it's just the way that their stomach
digests the food that they eat
through this digestion they emit this
methane
and rice it's another crop that emits
betaine there's one
special that we have working a lot it's
called alternate wetting and drying it
makes a better use of water while
growing rice but then it can reduce
almost 70 percent of the methane
that that rice crops could emit
another successful initiative by one
cgiar has been introducing technology
into smallholder farming these projects
called climate smart villages allow
farmers to use information about climate
variability to increase their crop
yields
are communities where
the cgr research program on climate
change agriculture and food security
ccaps
has been working for the past 10 years
and the idea is that in these places
we
co-generate knowledge with the
communities
in relation to
where the practices and technologies
that can
promote
food security increase productivity but
at the same time
that can help to build resilience
against climate viability and extremes
many times farmers feel that those
forecasts in terms of of climate so
precipitation temperature that it's it's
really hard to understand what all that
it's about and therefore they don't use
this information but when you start
co-generating this information with
farmers from the very beginning
a totally different thing starts to
emerge
and is that these farmers get really
interested in understanding this
information
and therefore they use it so what we
have been doing in many places latin
america
africa and asia is to co-develop with
holder farmers this climate information
so they understand what it's all this is
about
and they observe what is happening with
their mace with their rice with their
beans and then they can make these
relationships that sometimes us in our
laboratories are not able to observe so
what what this uh way of doing research
is bringing into the table it's really
working together getting the best of our
research getting the best of the
knowledge from farmers indigenous people
putting this information together and
then really make
been been sure that this information is
going to have an impact in the lives of
these
smallholder farmers
all of these programs by one cgiar
provide hope for smallholder farmers
but the reality of climate change
remains daunting
while we were producing our research and
innovation strategy for 2030 we did many
analysis in terms of the magnitude of
the challenge
and what we saw was if we don't really
work in terms of producing knowledge and
innovation in agriculture in environment
that it's in line with the climate
targets
what we would be seeing is that the
number of undernourished people around
the world
would go up to
820 million people by 2030
and also because of climate
extremes will have people having to move
having to be relocated on a number
around
200 million people by 2050. so this is
going to have huge consequences in terms
of undernourishment
in terms of food security and in terms
of the likelihoods of people that would
have to get away from the places where
they are because of crisis in relation
to water and because their souls are not
suitable anymore to grow the crops that
they were used to grow
the issues related to forced migration
because of climate change will not only
affect smallholder farmers and
populations in developing countries
coastal cities and communities around
the world will also face these
challenges as sea levels rise
paul edwards is director of stanford
university's program on science
technology and society and one of the
authors of the ipcc six assessment
report released in august 2021
sea level rise
comes from a multitude of sources
mainly from the expansion of the water
in the ocean it's known as thermosteric
expansion
that makes the sea
bigger just like it it expands
freeze water water also expands when it
get when it warms
so about half of the the sea level rise
is caused by ocean expansion the rest is
coming from the melting of land ice
glaciers on land which are melting all
over the world 95 percent of the
glaciers in the world are in retreat
and from the great ice sheets of
greenland and antarctica which are
melting ever faster and we have some
concerns about
really major increases in melting that
we've seen recently
at the temperatures we're about to
experience of one and a half to three
degrees probably sometime this century
sea level will rise enough
in the long run to inundate coastal
cities especially in asia
we're already seeing that in south
florida for example where
miami beach has regular floods that are
increasing in frequency
and causing the city to have to try to
raise the sidewalks and things like that
but those are just you know tiny
adjustments
they won't work in the long run to keep
our cities from being inundated
so we will have to pull back from the
coasts
as as the sea level continues to rise
there is time to do that because it's a
slow process
uh it's only about four millimeters a
year but it's increasing and we expect
it to
hit us ever harder as time goes on
i think the easiest way to get at the
question of risks to coastal cities is
to just talk about some experiences i've
had in florida
part of my family lives in the fort
lauderdale area and when i visit them i
hear them and their friends talking
about when should we sell our house
because it's going to be threatened by
sea level rise soon and we don't want to
lose all its value
now only a few people are probably
thinking that way right now but more and
more people will think that way over
time
and there you know it will start as a
trickle and then it'll become a flood of
people abandoning uh places near the
coast and trying to find somewhere else
to move
with sea levels rising countries will
need to address what they will do where
coastlines are under threat
so you sort of have two choices you can
spend mountains of money on sea walls to
protect a particular place
and that'll work for a while
or
you can manage that retreat and say
you know some of these buildings are
gonna go and we're gonna just
assume that and move back
california is actually just now
initiating a system for buying the land
of property owners along our some parts
of our coast where they're threatened by
sea level rise grace
to recycle at the paris climate accords
in 2015
196 countries agreed to limit global
warming to 1.5 degrees celsius
compared with pre-industrial levels
to achieve this global greenhouse gas
emissions would need to peak as soon as
possible in order to reach net zero by
mid-century
i am
not optimistic about our ability to stay
within that limit partly because
all the modeling we've done that
shows possible ways to get there
involves not only reducing emissions
to zero
very quickly but also removing carbon
from the atmosphere after that what they
call negative emissions and
yes there are ways to do that but there
is no way yet to do it efficiently
and i hope somebody listening to this is
going to invent some fabulous way to
remove carbon from the atmosphere so we
can
manage it and stay within that limit but
right now we don't have that tool
in addition to advances in point source
carbon capture and direct air capture
there are people working on other ways
to remove co2 from the atmosphere so we
can better adapt to and hopefully
mitigate some of the effects of climate
change
grace andrews is the director of
scientific operations for project festa
project vesta is an organization that is
fundamentally committed to helping
people thrive in the face of the climate
crisis and we are doing that by
developing a negative emission
technology called coastal carbon capture
which
actively removes carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere
and
moves it into the ocean in a safe and
stable form
fundamental scientific principle that
underpins coastal carbon capture is
something called chemical weathering
which is
a natural process that happens
all the time all around us so it happens
in your backyard every time water comes
into contact with rocks so every time it
rains it happens every time you water
your lawn this is happening and this is
removing carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere
and this process of chemical weathering
is the process that has regulated
earth's atmospheric co2 levels
on geologic time scales anyway
so for billions of years
and
this process although very effective at
controlling atmospheric carbon dioxide
levels is relatively slow
so what project best is trying to do is
simply accelerate this process so that
it happens
a little bit more quickly and is useful
for mitigating climate change
to reach this goal project vesta is
hoping to use a substance called olivine
which gets its name from its pale green
color the idea of using olivine to
remove carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere has been around for about 20
years
olivine is a mineral
it is a
naturally forming mineral that is
incredibly common it's found
just about everywhere unlike most
minerals it has a very special property
to it that when it comes into contact
with carbon dioxide
and water
it chemically reacts it dissolves very
slowly
and that chemical reaction
transfers carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere into the water and by that
way removes carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere and helps to mitigate climate
change
once that carbon is in the water it
stays in the water
for
thousands of years at a minimum we talk
about the residence time of
water in the ocean so once it's in the
water it circulates through the ocean
and it gets removed from the surface
layer of the ocean down to the bottom of
the ocean and then it takes a few
thousand years for that to come back up
now once it comes back up
there is the chance that it could
exchange with the atmosphere again
depending on the levels of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere at that future
point in time
but
right now we don't know what the
concentration of co2 will be in the
atmosphere in a few thousand years so we
don't know
what will happen to the carbon at that
point since coastal carbon capture would
mean spreading olivine on peaches one of
the first questions people ask is
whether it would turn shorelines green
no that is a misconception
we will not be turning any beaches green
so olivine
as a mineral when it is in sort of a
large grain size is quite green in color
it's really pretty actually but
when it is in a powdered or sand sized
it's more of a white color slightly
white pale green color
another question is how much would
project vesta's technology cost right
now we are estimating that coastal
carbon capture
will go for about somewhere between 50
and 70 dollars per ton of carbon dioxide
removed from the atmosphere
which makes it economically fairly
competitive some comparison figures
there would be direct air capture which
has been gaining a lot of attention
right now you know the cost estimates
around that suggest that could be closer
to 100 200 or more
dollars per ton of carbon dioxide
removed so this is a much more
inexpensive option than some of these
other technologies which makes it
attractive
so right now project vesta is still very
much in the research development or r d
phase
we are conducting
modeling studies to try and understand
coastal carbon capture dynamics in
different locations
we are conducting laboratory experiments
trying to constrain some of these
physical parameters
but we are also at the point where we
are launching our first pilot study of
coastal carbon capture
so
something that you know any scientist
can tell you is that you know you can do
all the laboratory experiments in the
world
but nature is very complicated
and so you won't really know how well
something works until you try it in
nature
so that is the next step that we have to
take with coastal carbon capture
we have launched our first pilot study
it's on a beach in the dominican
republic
and right now we are in what we're
calling the baseline monitoring phase
so we have not put olivine down on the
beach yet but we are taking months to
really carefully study
the natural chemistry and biology of the
site and and characterize it from more
or less every angle
so that when we do apply olivine we can
really robustly
quantify
any changes that occur
once we have
confidence in that safety and efficacy
our hope is that in five years from now
we will be capturing a million tons of
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere that
will multiply by 10 times for the
following five years up to the 10-year
mark where we will be capturing a
giganton of co2
[Music]
reaching this goal would mean spreading
olivine on a little more than just 0.2
percent of beaches around the globe a
number that scales up in a linear
fashion as more olivine is deployed the
greatest challenge though may not be the
technology
there's a technological challenge but
i think the biggest challenge for
coastal carbon capture is social license
you know
coastal carbon capture
it happens on
beaches and it only works when we work
with communities
so
it requires that communities
want to work with us and
i think rightfully so people are often
a little bit scared of the unknown a
little bit scared of taking risks you
know it's
because we messed with the planet that
we got ourselves into the climate change
problem to begin with and then coming in
and saying let's let's do something a
little bit different can make people
feel uncomfortable so i think that
social license is really the biggest
challenge for coastal carbon capture we
are not going to put olivine down
anywhere before we know it's safe you
know project fest is here because we we
care about the planet
we want you know we're here because we
are fundamentally committed to trying to
help you know the the earth recover from
from damages that have been done
we have no interest in hurting
the planet and
you know we work really closely with
you know regulating agencies so this is
not something that what can just be done
without consent from all relevant
parties from all stakeholders you know
we're not working anywhere where we're
not going through the rigorous
permitting process and meeting the
permitting standards there is often a
distrust around
scientists and scientific motivations
and i hope that
people watching this
can begin to understand that
the people that are behind these
technologies and that are committing
their lives and their careers to the
development of this work
we are just regular people that are in
this because we care about our own
families but also because we care about
your family
you know we are doing this because we
care about
planet earth and about humanity
you know as a scientist i have
confidence that we can develop the
technologies
to remove carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere or to limit carbon emissions
to the atmosphere
so it's not a question
of
if we can do it but
whether we want to do it as a society
you know
we can invent the technology but unless
people want us to deploy it
want us to be working with them then all
the technology in the world doesn't do
us any good
[Music]
you